punk it's a way of life it's like  Anarchy we do what we want they must be  from California  Sam what are you looking forward to  experiencing in croydon it's gonna be a  lot like just speaking suits admiring  sentences hello tell fat is Punk do more  Punk to me would you have to be [ __ ]  past 48 hours once worth very you will  stop doing what we're told  what you bring it over I slept at his  house and we engaged in complete sexual  activity hmm  losing its structure what is poem ode to  SIA smash the oppressor told the truth  being original blah blah blah I'm boring  myself now none of them you're just  jealous  if you allow her this freedom she may be  about ready to come home yet we have to  leave now  you must choose between this world and  our own  and for time up we like to dance  we like to fall in love we may have  mucked this planet up royally but at  least were alive and it would be thicker  more colorful somehow  but it's a good world  [Music]  you  you